What were you doing in Mexico?
Oh, okay.
A couple of people have been doing that.
Here's an essential part of entry
with the summer upon us.
We have high traffic, a lot of crossers.
So we're seeing an increase of narcotics
smuggling, people
smuggling.
COVID played a big role
with human smuggling.
Most of our smugglers are tourists
come from Mexico.
So when they're were restricted from
entering the country during the pandemic,
a lot of organizations
look towards United States citizens
to try and smuggle people
Hi. Good morning.
Whenever we have people
crossing every day.
99% of those people
there are legitimate travel.
But we have people
that will get documents in Mexico.
Either they buy the documents
or they steal the documents
and they present themselves
as that person.
Hi. Look in the camera.
So this facial recognition system,
it's an extra layer of enforcement for us.
To determine, one, that the person is
the person that she is presented.
Do you mind just taking the mask off?
I'm going to take a picture.
And also help us
determine their citizenship
when they presented US passport
Good afternoon.
Buenas tardes.
Okay.
Subject
presented a California driver's license
as her indentification.
When we did the biometrics
facial comparison,
the picture did not match the picture
that she probably has
with her US passport
so she was referred to secondary.
So we can verify that
that's the person within.
How are you, ma'am?
Okay. Have you had a U.S. passport?
Okay. Well.
What happened to your passport?
Okay.
She was very straightforward,
always was looking at me.
She didn't hesitate on responding
when we told her that we were going
to take the fingerprint.
That's usually a sign
that a person is being truthful
We took her fingerprints
and we corroborate that it was her.
Thank you for your cooperation
and you're good to go.
Have a good one.